- I would like you, as a talk show host,
to introduce our next guest.
(audience clapping)
- Okay great.
He played the Coleslaw King of The world
and Josie's brother, Rob.
Take a look.
- I am Josie Geller high school
student, senior class, 1999.
- Huh uh.
You're kidding, right?
- What?
- Josie, do you remember high school?
- It was a long time ago.
- Do you remember what they
called you in high school?
- [Kids] Josie Grossy, Josie
Grossy, Josie Grossy, Josie!
- Josie Grossy.
- Please welcome David Arquette.
(crowd cheering)
David.
- Okay.
I feel like I'm being punked. (laughs)
I was told we were all
gonna be wearing costumes.
(everyone laughs)
- I love it.
I love it.
And I want to say that
David and I have had
a really long history.
We grew up in the same neighborhood
right down the street from each other.
What was it like to know
each other, be friends,
and then get to play
brother and sister together?
- Yeah, it was, it was a dream come true.
I mean, you put this
beautiful film together
that was so heartfelt
and has stood the test of time.
And now you're here and
you're doing your show
and I'm so glad that like,
you get to see how much
the world loves you.
'Cause I love you and the world loves you.
- I love you too.
I have loved you my whole life, David.
You know, one of the scenes that I think
really resonated with people
was having Rob tell Josie,
which we all needed to hear
at some point in our life,
you can't be held back anymore
by your own personal insecurities.
And that's where the famous line comes in,
"I'm not Josie Grossy anymore!"
(audience cheers)
Because we need someone to see the thing
that we cannot see us for ourselves.
(upbeat music)